GILLIAN:  U.K. PRIME MINISTER
BORIS JOHNSON IS NOW OUT OF THE
HOSPITAL AFTER TESTING POSITIVE
FOR CORONAVIRUS JUST OVER TWO
WEEKS AGO.
JOHNSON DELIVERED THE FOLLOWING
VIDEO MESSAGE AFTER HIS RELEASE.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON.
I’VE TODAY LEFT HOSPITAL AFTER A
WEEK IN WHICH THE NHS HAS SAVED
MY LIFE.
NO QUESTION.
IT’S HARD TO FIND WORDS TO
EXPRESS MY DEBT.
BUT BEFORE I COME TO THAT, I
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE IN THE
ENTIRE U.K., THE EFFORT AND THE
SACRIFICE YOU HAVE MADE AND ARE
MAKING.
WHEN THE SUN IS OUT AND THE KIDS
ARE AT HOME, WHEN THE WHOLE
NATURAL WORLD SEEMS AT ITS
LOVELIEST AND THE OUTDOORS IS SO
INVITING, I CAN ONLY IMAGINE HOW
TOUGH IT HAS BEEN TO FOLLOW THE
RULES ON SOCIAL DISTANCING.
I THANK YOU BECAUSE SO MANY
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY HAVE BEEN
DOING THE RIGHT THING, MILLIONS
GOING THROUGH THE HARDSHIP OF
SELF ISOLATION, FAITHFULLY,
PATIENTLY, AND WITH THOUGHT AND
CARE FOR OTHERS AS WELL AS FOR
THEMSELVES.
I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT THIS
EASTER SUNDAY I DO BELIEVE THAT
YOUR EFFORTS ARE WORTH IT AND
ARE DAILY PROVING THEIR WORTH
BECAUSE ALTHOUGH WE MOURN EVERY
DAY THOSE WHO ARE TAKEN FROM US
IN SUCH NUMBERS, AND THE
STRUGGLE IS BY NO MEANS OVER, WE
ARE NOW MAKING PROGRESS IN THIS
INCREDIBLE NATIONAL BATTLE
AGAINST CORONAVIRUS.
FIGHT WE NEVER PICKED AGAINST AN
ENEMY WE STILL DON’T ENTIRELY
UNDERSTAND.
WE’RE MAKING PROGRESS IN THIS
NATIONAL BATTLE BECAUSE THE
BRITISH PUBLISHING FORMED A
HUMAN SHIELD AROUND THIS
COUNTRY’S GREATEST NATIONAL
ASSET, OUR NATIONAL HEALTH
SERVICE.
WE UNDERSTOOD AND WE DECIDED
THAT IF TOGETHER WE COULD KEEP
OUR NHS SAFE, IF WE COULD STOP
OUR NHS FROM BEING OVER WELL MED
-- OVERWHELMED, THEN WE COULD
NOT BE BEATEN AND THIS COUNTRY
WOULD RISE TOGETHER AND OVERCOME
THIS CHALLENGE AS WE HAVE
OVERCOME SO MANY CHALLENGES IN
THE PAST.
IN THE LAST SEVEN DAYS I HAVE OF
COURSE SEEN THE PRESSURE THAT
THE NHS IS UNDER.
I’VE SEEN THE PERSONAL COURAGE
NOT JUST OF THE DOCTORS AND
NURSES BUT OF EVERYONE, THE
CLEANERS, THE COOKS, THE
HEALTHCARE WORKERS OF EVERY
DESCRIPTION, RADIO OFFING GRAY R
PHARMACISTS, WHO KEPT PUTTING
THEMSELVES IN HARM’S WAY, KEPT
RISKING THIS DEADLY VIRUS.
IT’S THANKS TO THAT COURAGE,
THAT DEVOTION, THAT DUTY AND
THAT LOVE THAT OUR NHS HAS BEEN
UNBEATABLE.
I WANT TO PAY MY OWN THANKS TO
THE UTTERLY BRILLIANT DOCTORS,
LEADERS IN THEIR FIELD, MEN AND
WOMEN WHO TOOK CRUCIAL DECISIONS
A FEW DAYS AGO WHICH I WILL BE
GRATEFUL FOR THE REST OF MY
LIFE.
I WANT TO THANK THE MANY NURSES,
MEN, AND WOMEN, WHOSE CARE HAS
BEEN SO ASTONISHING.
I’M GOING TO FORGET SOME NAMES.
I WANT TO THANK PAUL INE,
SHANNON, BECKY, RACHEL, NIKKI
AND ANN AND I HOPE THEY WON’T
MIND IF I MENTION IN PARTICULAR
TWO NURSES WHO STOOD BY MY
BEDSIDE FOR 48 HOURS WHEN THINGS
COULD HAVE GONE EITHER WAY.
THEY’RE JENNY FROM NEW ZEALAND
AND LOUISE FROM PORTUGAL, NEAR
PORTO.
AND THE REASON IN THE END MY
BODY DID START TO GET ENOUGH
OXYGEN WAS BECAUSE FOR EVERY
SECOND OF THE NIGHT THEY WERE
WATCHING AND THEY WERE THINKING
AND THEY WERE CARING AND MAKING
THE INTERVENTIONS I NEEDED.
SO THAT IS HOW I ALSO KNOW THAT
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY 24 HOURS A
DAY FOR EVERY SECOND OF EVERY
HOUR THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF NHS STAFF WHO ARE
ACTING WITH THE SAME CARE AND
THOUGHT AND PRECISION AS JENNY
AND LOUISE.
THAT IS WHY WE WILL DEFEAT THIS
CORONAVIRUS AND DEFEAT IT
TOGETHER.
WE WILL WIN BECAUSE OUR NHS IS
THE BEATING HEART OF THIS
COUNTRY.
IT IS THE BEST OF THIS COUNTRY.
IT IS UNCONQUERABLE.
IT IS POWERED BY LOVE.
SO THANK YOU FROM ME, FROM ALL
OF US, TO THE NHS.
LET’S REMEMBER TO FOLLOW THE
RULES ON SOCIAL DISTANCING, STAY
AT HOME, PROTECT OUR NHS, AND
SAVE LIVES.
THANK YOU, AND HAPPY EASTER.
GILLIAN:  THAT WAS BORIS JOHNSON
WITH A MESSAGE OF THANKS JUST
AFTER BEING RELEASED FROM THE
HOSPITAL.
HE PLANS TO RECOVER AT HOME FOR
A LITTLE WHILE LONGER AT THE
ADVICE OF HIS DOCTORS BEFORE